[Music]
whose land is
this my
land well well well our war hero has
arrived you been a good choice coming
back here most say are the finest
wealthiest and most beautiful people on
God's Earth man yeah it's smart
everybody they have the say who gets the
oil son I got a question you like women
that's my
weakness well we mix these families
together and that estate money flows the
right direction it'll come to us show
Mei that's how you are I don't know what
you said but must have been Indian for
handsome
[Music]
devil why did you come
here I work with my uncle you scared of
him oh he's a he's the nicest man in the
world the old sage their time is over we
got to take back control of your
home I sent down from Washington DC to
see about these
murders we have so many deaths we've
lost count this just bad luck seems more
like an epidemic than bad luck to
me those SES Dying by the enemy do not
let them die
alone evil surrounds my
heart you going to pick a
side I don't even know if you love me
anymore of course I love you and kill
these men who killed my
family did your wife say who she was
most afraid of
don't do something you're going to
regret for the rest of your
[Music]
life I ain't got nothing but
regret
[Music]
a